Martha made history with her Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue cover at 81
years
old first of all ma'am goodness every
81-year-old out there is like this is
not like the others like this is like
like it's incred why now like this is
incredible I wonder I they never asked
me before yeah I would I would have done
it when I was 40 I looked great at
40 well they think you look great at 81
too so it's it's just I love that you
you did it too I think it it was the
most popular one right yeah of the
covers yeah we got like many many
billions of it was
crazy I do think though you Agee really
well so I don't know if that's
comparable to the rest of us but um I
don't know did your did your mother
influence you didn't she kind of
influence your attitude
mom was great and mom was mom was
beautiful and with it and totally alert
and and intelligent and she raised six
kids no and uh and she was great until
the the day she passed away at 93 so
she's a and she never sick and she was
uh she was fantastic she was swimming
every day you know she's an amazing
woman what a great role model as well
very very good role model well you were
following in those footsteps are yeah I
was like
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home